joining me now is newt gingrich former
speaker of the house and fox news
contributor
now new we tried to warn everyone during
covid that this was kind of a warm-up
act to what they ultimately wanted to do
we've heard rumblings about this from
bill gates who said the climate's much
worse than covid so why not have a
global pause or shut down every now and
then how do you see this playing out
well first of all i want to say that may
be one of the most brilliant
monologues i've heard you give
in a long time of listening to you that
was just absolutely brilliant
uh and uh i thought it was stunningly
accurate
look people like bill gates have two key
characteristics
their religious fanatics on behalf of a
series of values
that are weird and
they're hypocrites
they don't mind flying around the world
in private planes they don't mind having
huge houses with enormous amounts of air
conditioning they don't mind the size of
their carbon footprint it's a classic
example what you have is a power elite
which thinks that climate is the
emotional excuse
to control the rest of us and this goes
all the way back to a robert heilbronner
article in 1992 when he said now that
the soviet union is gone we need a new
excuse to take control and climate and
the environment is probably the best
excuse we're going to get
these people are
fundamentally dishonest what they're
trying to do is by any reasonable
standard crazy if you look at what's
happening in germany where they're going
back to coal plants
where they're about to go back to
nuclear power if you look what's
happening all around the world
the cost of elite rich people trying to
impose theoretical ideas on the real
world
the collapse of the government of sri
lanka
is a direct result of this more pain is
coming and i think
someday historians will look back and
say these were truly bad people
horrible human beings and newt the u.n
chief antonio guterres spoke out
yesterday about this so-called emergency
this has to be the decade of decisive
climate action
that means trust multilateralism and
collaboration
we have a choice collective action or
collective suicide
it is in our hands
collective suicide newt is that what
we're facing here do you notice they're
all reading from the same hymnal here
everyone's saying the same thing how can
that be
okay laura this is so
fundamentally dishonest
that it's crazy
if you go back all the way to
paul ehrlich and the population bomb in
the 1970s the left has consistently
argued that we're on the edge of a
gigantic crisis ehrlich said by 2000
great britain would be starving to death
totally false
go back and take everything that uh al
gray that
the al gore put in his movie
go through it step by step it's all a
bunch of lies it didn't happen it's not
true
the idea of the you know human race is
not on the edge of collective suicide
unless it's by nuclear war but we're
certainly not in the edge of collective
suicide because of climate uh and i
think the elites are so frenzied they
all go to the same cocktail parties they
all talk to each other they all come to
an agreement that they're going to say
this nonsense and going to reinforce
each other the truth is it's false just
as by the way the same elites were lying
to us about covet as we now grudgingly
slowly are learning so i think the
average person ought to realize your
elites are lying to you
now new there was a moment at the white
house briefing today where the press
secretary was asked about the
president's relative absence over the
last three days from the public scene
watch
what exactly has he been doing yesterday
today so he's been in meetings he's been
meeting with his senior staff he's been
meeting with
a staff he's just been very busy uh
dealing with the issues of the american
people and meeting with his staff and
senior staff the last two days
newt lots of meetings even the left is
turning on him
look i i don't know whether i prefer joe
biden publicly incomprehensible and
suffering clearly cognitive decline or
joe biden hiding while his staff
protects him as he suffers cognitive
decline but certainly if you watched him
on the trip to the middle east it was a
total embarrassment for the united
states and for those of us who believe
in freedom and i just think you have to
start with the idea that this guy is
being manipulated by his staff whatever
they're about to do in the environment
will be an act of desperation but given
that they've given uh john kerry a major
role you just have to assume it'll be
crazy because carrie's crazy uh these
are people who believe in a fantasy
world that does not exist could not
possibly be defended in a serious public
debate
new great to see you as always tonight
thank you so much hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else